welcome uh to uh rostovsev lecture um
sponsored by uh the uh stuffsev fund in
the classics department at yale
um it's lovely to have such a large and
such an international audience it's the
silver lining of zoom
um
so i'm going to speak very briefly uh
just to sort of introduce the lecture um
and uh some of you have heard this story
before but um when i was first chair uh
happily it hasn't been all along but uh
the first time um in 2007 our wonderful
administrative assistant came to me one
day and she said do you know what this
this ross trust rust this new fund is
and i said
i do not so we looked and we learned how
to pronounce the name and uh discovered
that um uh
raseb's widow had left us
um a substantial uh amount of money um
in in a proper uh endowment um and
um
with nothing
no strings on it except that it was to
support the teaching and research of
ancient history and archaeology at yale
and ancient history at yale in 2007 was
not nearly as strong as it is now and it
seemed to me that a good thing to do
would be to um to advertise and to give
put some
wind under its wings
so i started
this lectureship and then later
a rastaf traveling fellowship in
archaeology which has supported graduate
students from a number of different
departments over the years
and of course ancient history at yale is
now uh flourishing um and uh joe manning
noelensky andrew johnston and jessica
lamont all work together every year to
pick uh the lecturer and uh to do
activities around um the the annual
lecture
so you all know who mikhail ivanovich
rastaff was and how important his work
has been in shaping the various ways of
doing ancient history and archaeology
he came to yale by a circuitous route
the collapse of the romanov empire and
the triumph leninist bolshevism drove
him from russia in 1918
accompanied by his wife he spent two
years in oxford in 1920 he was offered a
chair at the university of madison
university wisconsin madison where he
remained for what he termed the happiest
years of his life
in 1925 he came to yale where he was
made sterling professor of ancient
history and classical archaeology and in
1927 he undertook and directed the yale
excavations at dura europas uh which of
course had a profound impact on the
composition of the classics department
here for the next few decades and on um
archaeology uh of the uh
we don't call it late antiquity at that
point do we but of of of the empire um
and going on uh from the fall of dura uh
for many many years
um will william colder wrote of him in
the um
the biographical dictionary of north
american classicists said he showed
americans how to get things done he
frightened most of them he never became
say the lecturer president of the apa or
even chairman at yale but he was
in the sense that nothing will be the
same after him and there are a few of
those
of whom that may be said
tonight's lecturer is one of whom that
might be said
jessica lamont will introduce him but i
want to record a personal pleasure that
this year's lecturer is roger bagnell
who was a terrific guidance and support
to me when we were rebuilding the yale
milk department
so with no further ado i turn it over to
jessica lamont
thank you so much chris um hi everyone
my name is jessica lamont i'm an
assistant professor in the department of
classics here at yale
um a hellenist as chris mentioned in our
combined program in ancient history
and it's really a pleasure tonight to
welcome and introduce roger bagnol
who has graciously stuck with us
as his lecture transformed from an
in-person event in which she was meant
to present on a grand stage and then
attend a reception and a dinner
um with with real live humans
into this remote event on zoom
which at least comes with a big audience
from around the world
so thank you roger for this and thanks
to all of you in attendance with us
tonight
so roger was an undergraduate student in
the department of classics here at yale
where he graduated with various honors
and distinctions
before going on to receive his ma and
phd at the university of toronto
he spent the bulk of his career 33 years
as j professor of greek and latin and
professor of history at columbia
university
during which he served as dean of the
graduate school of arts and sciences
and chair department of classics
he then joined the nyu faculty in 2007
as a professor of ancient history and
the director of the institute for the
study of the ancient world
um in many ways roger is the ideal
rustop zef lecturer as he like rastafa
is a titan in the field of ancient
history
and he specializes in the social and
economic history of the hellenistic
roman and late antique worlds
roger's work is also interdisciplinary
combining documentary evidence
especially that from papyri
with archaeological evidence to
illuminate complex social histories
and like christophs up roger also
undertakes and directs field work
roger leeds and white excavation project
at um
jointly sponsored with colombia in the
dhaka
in egypt
his recent book in oasis city presents
some results from this work
now among roger's other well-known books
are egypt in late antiquity
reading papyri writing ancient history
the oxford handbook a papyri and
everyday writing in the greco-roman east
and while his publications are extensive
and have been extremely influential in
ancient history circles
i thought i'd call attention
to a less well-known article of rogers
written in the year 1986
called the computer and classical
research
now in this 34 year old article which i
read last night
roger takes readers through the exciting
potential for research and learning that
the computer
could have for the future of classical
scholarship
34 years ago roger speculated on the
benefits that technology might one day
have for our field
from the existence of machine readable
files to the dissemination of the
results of one's research
now i couldn't help but wish that past
roger could see roger tonight
here in the current moment
presenting from his computer to an
audience across the world
sharing images and text from his ongoing
research with all of us tonight
so without further ado here is roger
bagnell
speak to us on the other caravan cities
transport capital and inequality in the
egyptian oases thank you
thank you
it is true that without technology um i
would just be
having dinner at home tonight
um which wouldn't be so bad but anyway
uh thank you very much jessica and thank
you to the department for inviting me
it is surely among the
least of the many dismal consequences of
the covet 19 pandemic that i am unable
to be speaking today in the yale lecture
hall to a live audience
i am in fact in st louis
trying like most grandparents it seems
to help with my grandchildren's remote
schooling
and yet i feel the loss of presence
when i was back for my 50th reunion two
years ago many memories came back
of my undergraduate formation in the
school of rostov staff kind of the slide
please joe
it was a period of bitter struggle in
the classics department whether that
legacy would survive
but through it all i learned much about
what it meant to be an ancient historian
from rostov's academic heir see bradford
wells
and wells students john oates and alan
samuel
both of whom
had left yale before i graduated
and also from jerry pollett not only
from his teaching but from my two years
of working for him
in the department slide collection
which had a profound impact on my career
it is a joy to see ancient history and
archaeology so strong at yale in this
century
rostov's caravan cities was published in
1932.
it was the translation of the
substantial rewriting and expansion of a
russian version of his travel sketches
published the year before
and was based on further travel in the
near east after the appearance of the
russian version
publishing must have moved faster before
modern technology
intervened
the preface tells us that the choice of
cities was accidental
based on the state of preservation of
their ruins petra jerosh palmyra and
dora
actually it is not an accident that
damascus aleppo and a man were less
susceptible to study
because they had modern cities on top of
the ancient sites
rustopsif's choice of what is today
jordan and syria for his travels was
also a reflection of his interests
and of course of yale's involvement in
the excavations at both dora and jarrosh
at the time
the underlying premise of the book and
the source of the concept of caravan
cities
is that the ancient cities of the near
east were never self-sufficient
they always had to trade to supply their
needs for goods not available locally
although some of this trade could go by
water much of the interior of the region
could not be reached except overland
the cities studied in the book all met
that criterion
as indeed would have those he omitted
rostov's step thus began with an
emphasis on the needs of producers and
consumers
and the role of caravan trade in meeting
those needs
it is all the more striking to see that
in the remainder of the historical
survey that opens the book and even more
in the succeeding chapters
the agency and motives of producers
consumers and merchants
are largely elided in favor of the role
of government
in effect the economics of the trade got
little attention
but a moment's thought must show that
only if the trade was economically
viable with those governments have cared
how did the economics work
and what were the consequences
by the time we get to jerosh where
rustoffsteff admitted that there was no
direct evidence of a role for trade in
the city's obvious wealth next slide
please
the absence of any other visible source
of prosperity was sufficient in his eyes
to justify the characterization of it as
a caravan city
the book's origins and travel sketches
become increasingly clear as it goes on
economic analysis is
unusually for rostov's death barely
present
there's these near eastern travels did
not include egypt
although he did visit it on other
occasions
egypt is not however entirely missing
from caravan cities
rostov's death stresses the close
connections between egypt and the near
east from at least the fourth millennium
bc on
but he saw correctly that transportation
inside egypt was above all by water
on the nile and so by the first
millennium and indeed i would say
earlier was its external trade which
used particularly the maritime routes to
the ports of the levant
he also pointed to the role of overland
caravans in connecting his caravan
cities to egypt mainly through the neck
of land connecting the nile valley to
sinai
but no egyptian city figures as a
caravan city in his account
this is perhaps not surprising because
the egyptian cities known to him were
all on the mediterranean the red sea or
the nile
those with which i shall be dealing were
hardly known at the time he wrote
it is perhaps telling that the word
oasis does not even figure in the index
to the book
one has to remember the travel
conditions of the era
rostov steph missed visiting petra two
decades earlier because quote it was
necessary to equip a caravan to find
guards and to obtain an erade from the
turkish officials unquote he lauds the
english who have quote like the romans
before them brought order and safety
good roads and new means of transport
end of quote
but petra was relatively easy to reach
compared to the oasis of egypt's western
desert
apart from a few early explorers there
was no archaeology in these oases before
ahmed fakhri began work in the 1960s
and the oases occupy the most modest of
places in the ancient written sources
that were known in rostov steph's time
next slide please
there are five principal oases in the
western desert of egypt forming an ark
that begins with siwa in the north
continues through bahrain and farapha in
the middle and finishes with dashlan
kharga
the distances that stake are large even
in modern terms
about 300 kilometers from paritonion
modern marsa matruch on the coast to
siwa about 400 kilometers from seawater
bahraia 175 from bahrain for afra 300
from for aphrodite and just under 200
from dakla to karga
similarly distances from any of them to
the valley are vast ranging from a low
of about 200 kilometers from bahrain to
oxarincus to 365 kilometers by the
direct route from dakhla to the valley
and much the same from bahrain to modern
cairo or ancient memphis
siwa is in a class by itself
even when one reaches the sea at
paraitonion it was still another 300
kilometers along the coast to alexandria
geologists will tell you
even if not asked
that oasis is a misnomer
these are depressions in the high desert
plateau where the ground level is
several hundred meters closer to the
water table than on the plateau
next slide please
in prehistory and early history there
were artesian springs
by the roman period water depended on
extraction via wells and cannots
those underground channels running
downhill from aquifers next slide please
only the area around these water sources
or their outlets can be cultivated
and would meet the modern concept of an
oasis
there are many
many such small oasis in each depression
but this geological purism does not
actually correspond to the meaning of
oasis in either egyptian or greek
just
as in english the ancients used it as we
do to refer to the whole of a depression
my focus will be on the oasis and their
relationship to egypt that is the nile
valley
in other words on the oases as
destinations and points of origin for
caravan traffic
as producers and consumers
the degree to which they were also waste
stations on longer caravan routes
and thus more analogous to the classic
caravan cities
as rostov's book portrayed them
has been debated
to the south
now the focus has been on the route
later known as the darba al-arabain
the 40 days track which in the medieval
and ottoman periods was a major route
for trade in gold and slaves from
sub-saharan africa to the mediterranean
it ran south from the tip of the cargo
oasis to darfur
but its use is not clearly attested
before the medieval period
that does not mean it was not used at
all
we should be open to the kind of
reevaluation that andrew wilson has
brought to trans-saharan trade through
the fazan
but even that was not as wilson has
shown
a through trade route driven by demand
in africa or in the roman world as in
later times
rather it involved the need on the part
of the garamantean agricultural
civilization to export its surplus and
import what it lacked
the garamantians did not pass on roman
goods to its trading partners to the
south
the residents of the egyptian oasis are
the counterparts of the garamantians
with connections to the west we are
somewhat better informed
already in the 5th century a route
between the fazan and siwa via algila is
attested by herodotus taking we're told
about 20 days
next slide please
it is for reasons i shall come to not
likely that this root was in use much
before that time
from siwa of course one could then reach
bahrain from there the fiam in the nile
valley
one medieval source places the fazan at
60 days travel via this route to cairo
perhaps a slight exaggeration
there is very little evidence
whether literary documentary or
archaeological
for active traffic along this route in
the roman period
the very scarce finds of african red
slipwares in the great oasis tell us
nothing
about the route by which they arrived
which is at least as likely to have been
by coastal trade from tunisia transport
up the nile and oasis traffic with the
valley as it is directly across the
desert via siwa and the chain of oasis
and there is nothing so far identified
in the finds or culture of the oasis
to suggest strong connections across the
sahara
or with libyan nomadic populations
the possibilities of economic life in
the oasis
were driven above all by two constraints
that were also opportunities
water
and distance
i will talk further about each of these
but first it is worth reflecting briefly
on the other resource the resources that
the oasis had or lacked
they had soil
from the breakdown of rock
and from solids and irrigation water
but it was at perennial risk of
destruction either by the occasional
flash flood something documented at
aldair in the cargo oasis
or more commonly by being blown away by
the north wind a perennial fact of life
but apparently more vigorous in some
periods than in others
we have probably lost more than a meter
of ancient settlement debris at amheda
the site in dakhla where i have directed
an excavation since 2004.
retaining agricultural soils was thus a
permanent challenge
there was however plenty of sand
this is perhaps not a surprise to anyone
but it should not be taken for granted
the same north wind that carries away
topsoil brings down sand dunes from the
plateau into the oasis depressions and
moves them steadily southward at a good
clip
about seven meters a year as we have
measured it at amheda next slide please
these dunes vary in size but some are
very large
this will give you an idea of the scale
the next slide please
plantations such as orchards
the agricultural middle class seems not
to have existed
sixth
instead
we find landlords and tenants
but not as in the valley tenants with
some independence negotiating time
limited leases
rather
tenants apparently existing in
continuing dependent relationships with
the owners of the wells
and of course in this context landlord
means someone who controls water
and extracts rent from it
and seventh the capitalists behind the
wells were to some degree absentees
some of them undoubtedly lived in hibis
mothus and sophis which was the capital
of bahraia
but others lived in the valley
they depended on a managerial class at
multiple levels
much as the wealthiest landlords in the
valley did
the higher managers might well even be
members of the city council themselves
and some of them may have owned shares
and wells too
the terminology of our texts does not
make it easy to tease out these complex
and hierarchical relationships
but we can at least say that management
played a larger role in the economy than
in regions where independent farmers and
small urban landowners were major
factors as they were in the valley
these managers were of necessity
literate so education was needed
now some second order
consequences the written documentation
from the oasis before the 4th century is
relatively scanty
and the 4th century and beginning of the
5th also formed the period best known
from archaeology
for various reasons i do not think this
was the most prosperous period of these
islands of habitation and the picture
i'm giving of the society of the waste
of the oases is largely of its last
phase
before a rapid decline with the
abandonment of many sites it is possible
that things were somewhat different in
the first three centuries of roman rule
but because the underlying structural
basis of the society was already present
from the start of the roman period if
not before i think that most of what i
am saying about it was true throughout
the imperial period
i've argued that this society lacked the
great middle groups that we know from
ptolemaic and roman egypt
on the one hand the traditional royal
farmers are public farmers with
long-term tenancy of land owned by the
crown or the state
enjoying many protections and stability
of conditions
they had paid a relatively high
proportion of their crop to the state
and it doesn't matter whether we call
that rent or tax
but the state knew that its revenues
depended in large part on this
population
and it usually made sure that they were
not dispossessed or seized for debt
creditors could not take their land
on the other hand perhaps a third of the
rural population owned their own farms
of sufficient size to support a family
these two groups are not attested in the
oases
what we have instead is five important
groups
first the tenants working the land
watered by the wells
we know them almost entirely
excuse me
from texts
mainly austrica and the kellis account
book
which mentioned them in connection with
the products of these wells particularly
on brief texts written as tags from jars
of wine the next slide please
second the transport workers whose
importance i have already stressed
donkey drivers and camel drivers
responsible for the raising care and
exploitation of these animals
as well as wagoneers
third artisans and service personnel
mostly of groups well known from the
valley
potter smiths builders furniture makers
cobblers linen weavers fullers millers
retail merchants bath attendants
locksmiths butchers tailors undertakers
and the like
along with the more distinctive oasis
occupation of well cleaner
fourth the managers both the local
agents well known from the documents and
the higher level supervisors
and fifth the capitalists
mostly landlords gaiukoi they were
called and we call them except that
waterlords might be more descriptive or
tree
lords and also some lenders who financed
caravan trips to and from the valley
this last group is barely known to us
from a couple of contracts next slide
please
and they may have in some cases been the
same as the owners of wells
but in many instances they were probably
intermediaries between the landlords and
the transporters
serving in effect as brokers
in this society the missing middle is
filled mainly with artisans and managers
perhaps the transport workers also
belong here but i do not think so
those whose names are given all have
egyptian names
this might seem unimportant but it is
not
when rodney asked and i analyzed the two
key populations of the tremethus
austrica we found that the tenants whose
names appeared on the wine jar tags
virtually all had egyptian names next
slide please
the managers in contrast almost all had
greek or roman names
the next slide please
the contrast is stark
and i must admit that it surprised us
we are accustomed to great caution in
the use of names as evidence after 600
years of greek and roman rule with all
of the cultural complexity that this
brought
not to speak of intermarriage of the
immigrant populations with locals
in the valley we do not find such stark
differences in naming
now we know nothing of the genetic
background of these oasis groups in the
4th century oasis
but from a cultural standpoint it is
clear that they are very distinct
the managerial class with its classical
education for which we have a lot of
evidence in
oasis names its children accordingly
next slide please
and this at least ought to make the
classicists in the audience feel at home
even if egypt is otherwise alien to them
just to be clear i will say that i am
not suggesting that we should return to
the view of egypt as a proto-feudal
society that paparologists have been
struggling to escape ever since h.i bell
put it forward a century ago
most historians today would accept the
view that late antique egypt was a more
unequal society than hellenistic or
early roman egypt
and that this inequality rested to a
large degree
on an increased concentration of land
ownership
but the rest of the legal and social
baggage of bell's proto-feudalism is no
longer alive in contemporary scholarship
in the oasis land ownership per se is
not at stake
it is wells an investment in
long-maturing tree crops that are
critical
this capital intensive economy does
share with the valley a larger role for
investment in infrastructure
and a monetized market for high value
crops
than was true in the egypt of an earlier
period
but because of the water regime and
distance
is a far pure instance of a capital
dominated society
we have no data to allow us to measure
inequality in this society
i cannot offer any genie coefficients
alas
but let us look at one indicator that to
my mind is significant
illegitimacy
i've discussed this more fully elsewhere
reassessing the argument made by herbert
judy a half century ago that
illegitimacy in the papyri of roman
egypt reflects marriage restrictions
imposed by the roman government
rather than as they put it the loose
morals of a low-class population
now the negative side of his case is
strong
people with only a mother's name appear
wherever the evidence allows us to say
to come from stable domestic
relationships in which the parents
simply are not legally married
the positive side of his argument
however does not stand
the use of mother's names
for identification persists long after
the disappearance of the prohibition on
soldiers marriages
or on intermarriage and long after the
antonine constitution
it is rather i've argued the product of
a society with significant economic
inequalities
that allow men of greater means to have
families perhaps second families
with what we would call concubines
as it happens there's a lot of evidence
for illegitimacy in the oasis texts
both in the third to fourth century
archive of the funeral workers of qsys
and in the austrica from kellis and
tremethus
the incidence of illegitimacy appears to
be higher than in contemporary archives
valley
we are of course familiar with the
phenomenon of a society in which the
economically disadvantaged are less
likely to marry than those of higher
economic status
we live in it
but perhaps even more striking is the
picture that i have sketched of the
oasis
and equally familiar to us today
is the role of elite education in
reproducing inequality from generation
to
generation
that the wealthy of roman egypt
supported classical education
for their male offspring is by now well
documented and we know quite a lot about
that educational process
what is more striking is the link
between classical education and the
managerial ranks
not only at the top but at the local
level
the close similarity of the handwriting
of the manager who maintained the kallus
account book
and that of one of the writers of the
codex of isocrates tablets found in the
same room
is not an accident
in the recent publication of a 4th
century codex of mathematical problems
and sample contracts the next slide
please alexander jones and i have argued
that it is a witness to the deliberate
formation of managers
the school of management attended after
a primary and even secondary education
in the classics
there is no investment without risk
and the wealthy residents of the valley
who invested in adding to the stock of
wells and the oasis in the early years
under roman rule must have taken account
of the risks that they could recognize
at the time
these may not have been entirely the
same as those that affected investment
decisions in the 4th century
it's difficult
to separate out a recognition of risks
from an attempt to understand why the
oasis declined steeply
in late antiquity
across dakota there is a horizon of
abandonment or at least partial
abandonment in the 360s and a reduced
level of occupation afterward
we have less good information for karga
but at least the southern part of that
oasis has little to show after the first
decades of the fifth century
much the same is true of bahrain
there are four main potential risks that
i can see
the first is the possibility that wells
will stop producing water
or require so much deepening that they
are no longer economically viable
today's mechanized drilling can reach
lower aquifers than the ancients were
capable of tapping
we do not know what the lifespan of an
ancient well was
and i do not
see how except with unlikely extensive
excavation
excuse me
we will ever find out
a second risk is markets
if demand for oasis products were to
fall
or prices to soften because of increased
competition from cultivation in the high
land along the valley
the profitability of the enterprise
could be threatened because high
transportation costs would erode profit
margins and harm competitiveness
a third risk is the security of the
oasis
we do
know in fact that there were some
attacks on karga in later centuries and
insecurity may have started to be a
factor in the third century
it was under the tetrarchy that the
first permanent military installations
in the oasis appear to have been built
more or less simultaneously in bahrain
dakhla and karga next slide please
whether these were responding to past
attacks or represent a more
forward-looking apprehension we do not
know
there is next to no documentation of
desert insecurity in this period
finally it is also possible that the
insecurity of lines of communication
the caravan roots themselves might have
threatened commerce even if the oasis
themselves were secure
there is no chain of military posts in
the desert to secure the roads and we
have no way of knowing if increasing
attacks on caravans might have raised
the effective cost of goods beyond what
it was possible to recover in the
markets of the valley
in effect even without any system of
insurance the risk level for caravans
may have risen beyond bearable levels
we lack the data to assess the
contribution that these risks made to
abandonment and thus investment failure
in the 4th and 5th centuries
the relative speed and simultaneity of
abandonment at different sites in dakla
in the 360s
makes me doubt that failure of the wells
was at stake
it is not likely that the water level
would have fallen so rapidly and in so
many different areas
the lifespan of wells may well have
caused investors to factor that in when
looking at return
but it is not likely to have been a
source of catastrophic risk
shifts in prices and competitiveness are
also not likely to have been so sudden
though they may indeed have happened
for these reasons i believe security is
a more likely candidate
but whether the oasis were directly
attacked and there is no evidence for
this in the fourth century and the
abandoned sites show no sign of
disturbance
or the caravan roots were subject to
plundering it is hard to say
we also cannot at this point say whether
investors could have seen these risks
coming already a century earlier
or if they became visible only suddenly
in the middle of the fourth century
nor yet do we know how long the roman
army remained in their oasis sports
they were certainly still there in the
360s
but for how much longer is not clear
qsys and south karga probably still had
some soldiers in the first two decades
of the early 5th century but it was not
a major garrison site
a lot of things had to come together for
the economic growth visible in the oasis
in the roman period to have been
possible
and obviously they did
most of them had been in place already
for a half millennium
and they had undeniably led to an
expansion of settlement
water technology
long distance transportation
a distinctive niche in the production of
valuable crops
it is possible that the roman period
brought new crops in the form of cotton
and perhaps milan but above all it
brought a tax regime favorable to the
investment of private capital
that capital found the combination of
the other factors attractive
it was not until the egyptian government
in the time of nasser decided to expand
settlement in the oasis that the oasis
would again be as densely settled as in
roman times
but that visible prosperity came at a
human cost
part of that cost was a high level of
inequality and a segmentation of the
population very different from what we
find in the nile valley
the key to the viability of the system
was estate management
and that was possible only with the
literate tools required for record
keeping
and reporting
teachers of the classics found a ready
audience in the future agents of capital
you can draw any moral for yourself
thank you
possibly the sound of one hand clapping
there roger thank you so much
um i think joe is going to take uh
help help manage questions um how do you
want to do it joe
i think if you all don't mind uh
questions via the chat so i can uh with
my colleagues feel them maybe
consolidate or feel them to together in
a a good single question that sort of
thing just to
we don't bombard roger um from all over
the place so if you don't mind we'll let
roger rest for 30 seconds catch his
breath and send your questions via the
chat please
in the meantime i should i can say what
i should have said at the beginning that
it is actually rostov's 150th birthday
today
so
well done
maybe question roger just myself to get
things going for a few minutes um and
ask you about the current work um that
you're doing um out there and um what
what is on your research agenda that
that you are looking for that might help
uh
flesh out this
this rise and decline story in the oasis
which is
rather dramatic
oh well um
we'd like to keep digging of course
um
you know as anybody who works in egypt
knows it's been impossible in recent
years
to get permission to
excavate in the oasis
they are in a military zone and the
military has not been giving permission
uh even though our permission from the
antiquities ministry has come through
every year we have not actually been
able to go out and dig
at the point that we were
stopped
uh we were beginning a house
to excavate a house that is much larger
than the rather large and lavish house
that we excavated at the beginning the
house of serenus with its wall paintings
and so forth
uh and this larger house i think has got
to be at least twice if not three times
the size of sirenis with much grander
and uh better built
banquet hall
and a lot of wall paintings and much
much higher quality plaster moldings and
stuff like this
so you know i would like to know whose
house that is right
that is
uh it has an enormous number of
um
austrica
from well tags uh these labels from wine
jars that we found in the first year we
dug in and that was the last year we
were able to work
so we have a huge amount still to do
in that house and we would really love
to get back to it to get another
person from that upper end of society
at the same time there's a lot more to
be done in humbler areas
and there's an area that seems to be a
century older than
these houses uh in another part of the
site that we surveyed
some years ago
after the dunes marched south and
uncovered it for us
uh where we would like also to work
because that area looks to have much
more like what we would think of as
roman urban planning
but the houses are also more modest and
we'd like to see what kind of people
live there
to get a you know a better sense of
you know is there really a middle class
that we're just totally missing up to
this point uh from the sites that we've
worked at
uh the egyptians have also been working
at another site aina sabil which has
yielded austrica that seem pretty much
to reflect the kind of
uh dare i say it today plantation
economy uh that i've been describing
and um
if we were able to work in daca it would
be a lot easier to collaborate with them
because they've been very open about
allowing us to work on the documents
they've found
okay uh the questions are kind of
rolling in now so if i may
um let me let me get to some of them uh
bear with me could it shift from bank
credit
um in the third century ce to
peer-to-peer credit in the fifth and
sixth century see have been a factor in
decline
i don't know that peer-to-peer credit
would have been a factor in decline we
certainly
uh do find it in earlier centuries it's
just that we find more of it and we
don't i and i don't think we find
significant bank credit
uh in that fashion at all actually
uh i don't think that
credit was in short supply
but it's possible that the
waterlords were more rapacious
with it and it's it's really very hard
to say because we don't have the
comparable documents from the earlier
period so we don't see credit
transactions happening in the oasis in
an earlier time
if the basis of the inequality was
structurally different how did this
express itself was it less more simply
shifted do you think it felt
qualitatively
qualitatively different
i'm sorry i didn't didn't hear that
clearly joke
if the basis of the inequality was
structurally different how did this
express itself was it less more or
simply shifted do you think it felt
qualitatively different
well i think the missing middle made it
qualitatively different we didn't have
as much of a continuum from the poor to
the rich
uh the the the gulf was much wider
and the managers were
if anything on the rich side of that
divide right because they got educated
and no doubt took off their share of the
revenues
whereas i think the transporters were
probably on the wrong side of that line
but without the middle group i think it
was that the extremity of it you know
the quantity is the quality in that
sense
do we have any contracts governing the
tenancy arrangements were these bound
tenants at scripted scripted were they
paid wages were they debt slaves also
tree crop production is often highly
labor intensive
water lifting costs and so on do we have
evidence of slave labor
there is certainly evidence for slavery
in the oasis but uh not as far as i know
for slave labor
in agriculture
we have no uh tenancy contracts
and if i remember correctly no uh no
real labor contracts either
um
what we have is
uh on the one hand the labels coming in
on the wine jars showing who the tenants
were and on the other hand the rent
rolls in the account book which were set
up with the names of the tenants which
basically are the same from year to year
over a three year period
and slayed down in advance the amount of
rent that was expected from them and
then entries made as they made payments
so it looks to have been an extremely
stable situation with not a lot of
variety
from year to year and probably not much
flux at
all this suggests to me a situation in
which the tenants had very limited
agency
two questions after my my own heart at
the moment what about climate change or
or disease as factors in decline roger
sorry climate change or what
what was the second or disease
disease
disease
yes
it's very likely that the oasis were
affected as the rest of egypt was by the
end of the roman climatic optimum
but because the water came from
underground
and had been laid down thousands of
years earlier
it is not likely to have been affected
in the way that the valley was by
changes in the
nile flood as a result of rainfall
patterns shifting
so i doubt that
uh that climate change is likely to have
made a lot of difference i don't think
changes in
temperature would have been particularly
harmful because the oasis are in general
hotter than the valley anyway
so if they'd cooled off just a few
degrees in the fourth century that
probably would have been a good thing
from their point of view
disease is harder to say
there certainly was plenty of disease
and also plenty of trauma
um
that we can find from the work of the
bio-archaeologists at kellis in
particular
but also aldair
and at ein lebanka in karga
but
the
chronology
of the burials is not precise enough as
far as i can see to give us a sense of
change over time
in what diseases were there and the
diseases that they have found mostly
don't look as if they are likely to have
been specific epidemics
that is to say i don't think we've got
enough evidence for the
um
second half of the second century to
hope to nail smallpox there
and on the other hand we don't have
cemeteries excavated so far
that date to the 6th century where we
might find bubonic plague so most of the
evidence that we have is in a
chronological fork that's not favorable
to finding that evidence
who owned the camels
hello jim
that is very hard to say actually
it um owner operators and hire drivers
in the in the trucking industry so can
we differentiate yeah
um
it is perfectly possible that those
existed
uh that some of the
camels belong to the
capitalists
and that they um
then that they hired camel drivers to
send their stuff to their markets
on the other hand the contracts
uh in genoa that i republished in the
gosco feschrift
it looks as if the transporters are
themselves the camel owners and they are
kind of you know independent agents
contracting
with a capitalist for the journey
there's a lot that's unclear in those
they're not very well drafted
but
it looks as if that is more nearly an
arms-length relationship
even though the same people clearly
contracted um in more than one year
if you take one more question maybe uh
at the late hour here um
what were their characteristics were
there unique characteristics of the
share contracts between the waterlords
and water infrastructure ownership
compared to other sorts of
proto-corporative contracts found in
other parts of egypt or the rest of the
mediterranean
sorry
i i lost the second half of that were
there any unique characteristics of the
share contracts between the waterlords
and the water infrastructure ownership
compared to other sources
proto-corporative contracts found in
other parts of egypt or the rest of the
mediterranean
unfortunately we don't have the
contracts between the waterlords and the
tenants uh all we have is the evidence
and the rent rules
of what was going on from year to year
so we
are left pretty much to guess from these
this external evidence at what the
nature of the relationship might be
this is deeply regrettable i would love
to have that kind of evidence but it
really looks as if it is something close
to customary and even hereditary
tendency there's one case where
it looks as if it passes from one member
of a family to another between two years
in the account book
so i suspect
it's very much in that kind of
hereditary frame
okay well roger thank you so much i
think i turn it over to to uh our chair
chris who would uh
invite us for a wonderful cocktail in
front of a beautiful fireplace
in new haven but
i'm going to go have a glass of bundle
that sounds very nice i actually asked
noel if he would just do the
do the end bit
oh yeah okay
happy to chime in here after such a
wonderful lecture um and uh right before
the lecture began i had sent an email to
roger and some of the other
co-organizers talking about how on some
level i think we probably all feel like
we've been living in oasis since last
march um all of us isolated in our
little um uh enclaves um hopefully with
family and friends um but uh and so far
as that's true i can say that this
evening at least we've
witnessed roger kind of uh bring us
drinks of cool intellectual water and
moreover to do things in a manner that
didn't obtain in
the western away season so far as he's
been so generous he's not a capitalist
with his knowledge he's great at sharing
it out so i think we can thank him very
much for all that he's taught us tonight
um and all that he's done to enlighten
us
thank you
and we should note that we hope to have
the host roger in the fall
in the beineckey to to have a kind of a
a pro seminar with papyri actually in
person we are keeping fingers crossed on
that
inshallah
yeah
good night everyone all right
thank you so much it's nice to see old
friends
and new friends